well fortunately no major delays at the
airport because of the wind but we did
talk with some International Travelers
tonight as recent numbers show Las Vegas
is once again a hot spot destination for
tourists 8 news now reporter Madison
Kimbrough was at Harry Reid
International today joins us live from
the strip tonight with the details
Madison
yeah the Las Vegas Convention and
visitors Authority just released their
preliminary visitation numbers for 2022
and it is safe to say that Las Vegas is
back welcoming tourists in full speed
many visiting here for the first time
it was just the first thing we thought
of to just come to Vegas now being able
to just hop on a plane and go and travel
this was really nice all International
Travelers aboard to Las Vegas Adrian and
Rebecca are visiting from Toronto a spur
of the moment trip neither have ever
been here before we picked up the
Bellagio to stay in because you might as
well do something very very nice I guess
uh I want to see caretop go to the Grand
Canyon in 2022 the second largest group
of foreign travelers to visit Las Vegas
were from Canada it's nice to get out of
the get out get to somewhere a little
bit warmer and have some fun I'm excited
to try the food I'm excited to go to the
to see all the hotels recently the Las
Vegas Convention and visitors Authority
released foreign travel numbers for last
year a whopping 3.4 million it breaks
years of decline mainly due to covid but
now international travel is making a
comeback
and with just a couple more days till
the official start of summer foreign
visitors like Sandy hoping to enjoy the
great outdoors here in the desert as he
traveled all the way from Europe along
with some hiking in the area of course
like Red Rock for example visits Grand
Canyon that's one of things the popular
sign yeah I'm gonna photograph that of
course and probably just try to look up
some casinos
lvcva reporting that over 60 percent of
Las Vegas's annual total of
international visitors come from Mexico
Canada and the United Kingdom reporting
here on the Strip Madison Kimbrough 8
News Now